es tan silencioso que se puede oír el
sonido de las escaleras mecánicas en la
sede de naciones unidas pero no hay
nadie en ellas este año la unne está
celebrando su 75 cumpleaños pero apenas
había invitados debido a la pandemia del
cob y 19 los líderes mundiales no
asistirán en persona y enviarán
discursos pregrabados
si este fuera un típico primer día de
una semana de alto nivel de la asamblea
general el martes habría unas 2500
personas apiñadas en esta sala este año
tendrás poco más de 200 personas en esta
sala ya no tendremos ese ambiente la
magia de tener todos los jefes de estado
de gobierno en una misma habitación no
habrá eso los micrófonos están
protegidos todo será limpiado estamos
casi solos en esta sala vacía excepto
extrañamente por el ruido de un niño
pequeño llorando pero no sé de qué se
trata
hace dos años en este mismo salón no
eran gritos sino risas lo que se
escuchaba en los delegados cuando el
presidente de eeuu donald trump daba su
discurso
no creo que nunca más se encuentre
divertido a donald trump en la onu este
año ha intensificado su agresiva
diplomacia en el sistema multilateral
retirándose de lado ms y emprendiendo
una gran pelea con aliados como francia
y reino unido- sobre la posibilidad de
sanciones seguidas
con la pandemia mundial una crisis
climática y el aumento de las tensiones
entre las potencias mundiales la
diplomacia es más necesaria que nunca
pero depende en gran medida del contacto
humano y eso faltará este año la gente
72 hartford se logra por supuesto menos
interactivo no habrá realmente reuniones
bilaterales para reemplazar el contacto
humano y por lo tanto necesitamos
urgentemente tener algo más que
videoconferencias simplemente son
insuficientes el lema del secretario
general de la onu en este momento es
recuperarse mejor se dirige a los
pasillos desinfectados de la onu el peso
del mundo sobre sus hombros